nous accueillons aujourd'hui alexandre
cédric douce et président de la société
de l'acadie du nouveau brunswick
bonjour monsieur doucet bonjour monsieur
doucet
nous vous accueillons aujourd'hui pour
discuter de la réforme de la loi sur les
langues officielles au canada
mais avant d'aller plus loin pouvez vous
nous présenter la société de l'acadie du
nouveau-brunswick
oui la société de l'acadie du nouveau
brunswick qui a été créée en 1973 et est
reconnu par les différents paliers
gouvernementaux soient fédéral et
provincial comme une organisme qui
représente politiquement les acadiennes
les acadiens ainsi que les francophones
au nouveau brunswick le canada s'apprête
à dépoussiérer sa loi sur les langues
officielles sont le français l'anglais
et la ministre et mélanie joly qui est
en charge du dossier a rendu public en
février dernier un livre blanc intitulé
vers une égalité réelle des langues
officielles
normalement un projet de loi serait
déposé d'ici la fin de l'année s'il n'y
a pas des élections fédérales entre en
cours de route mais votre organisme
la société de l'acadie du nouveau
brunswick avec d'autres groupes
francophones dans la même province
vous avez tiré la sonnette d'alarmé en
déplorant la non reconnaissance de la
spécificité acadiens dans cette réforme
de quoi s'agit-il dans les faits dans
les veines jeu dont on a toujours trouvé
que le livre blanc était excellent mais
puisque c'est pas un livre bar qui est
libre de consulter pour aller consulter
les différents acteurs un livre blanc
cdc des intentions législative du
gouvernement
donc ça doit être quand même assez clair
noir sur blanc et leur il manque
quelques détails qu'on voulait donner
l'aperçu public qui manquait donc
précisément ce qui manque pour nous
c'est que nous devons le cadre demande
depuis 2005 c'est que la reconnaissance
de l'acadie du nouveau brunswick qui se
retrouvent dans le préambule et dans la
zone d'interprétation de la loi ce que
ça se retrouve aussi dans la partie car
la partie qu'à toute la question des
services gouvernementaux que le
gouvernement fédéral doit donner et il y
aurait une clause qui dit que ses
services vers madrid doivent être des
langues officielles dans tout ce que
c'est oui il ya une demande importante
pour vous
vous voulez que ce soit donné partout
pas spécifiquement à l'importance de la
demande
on veut une zone qu'il ya une exception
pour le nouveau grand druide parce que
quand ce qu'on vante au nouveau
brunswick on rentre dans un territoire
qui est entièrement bilingue dont on
demande juste qu'il ya un arrimage la
chope canadienne des droits et libertés
qui reconnaît que le nouveau vendus
étaient bilingues ainsi que la loi sur
les langues officielles période qui
oppose qui donnent pas cette spécificité
leur don apprécié du tout
il ya deux autres endroits dans la loi
qu'on veut puis c'est dans la partie 6
pts plus particulièrement c'est qu'on
veut leur rapport à l'immigration
on veut que le gouvernement fédéral dans
ses politiques d'immigration tient
compte de l' équilibre linguistique du
nouveau brunswick donc on va loin des
migrations 50/50 l'immigration
francophone l'immigration anglophone
ensuite dessus dans la même partie sur
eux demande-t-il en son pouvoir de
dépenser et il tient compte de leurs six
à ce point de l'achat que l'adn des
droits et libertés la charte canadienne
des droits et libertés
ça donne le droit aux deux communautés
linguistiques d'avoir leur propre
institution distingue donc par exemple
ce qu'on demande dans ce pouvoir de
dépenser le dans la partie s'il sait que
le gouvernement fédéral subventionne des
instances distinctes pour la communauté
linguistique francophone du
nouveau-brunswick qui est
particulièrement vous donner des
exemples
l'une lost in mountain en tant qu'action
postsecondaire ou bien la petite enfance
que vous dualité exemple pour donner
pour illustrer ce concurrent ça mange ce
qu'on a eu la médaille au lycée qui est
dans son livre blanc il ya un vouloir de
reconnaître la spécificité du nombre en
duo mais ce qu'on veut c'est avoir des
détails ou ce soit spécifié si pour
seconde a donné on a envoyé comme kate
s'allie avec 18 ordinateurs
personnellement j'ai parcouru le livre
blanc je suis pas spécialiste
constitutionnaliste
j'ai relevé que le nouveau brunswick il
est cité à plusieurs reprises et magna
un endroit où on dit que c'est une
proposition législative je parle pas des
préambules on dit que je paraphrase à un
moment on dit que et de cela comprend le
fait que le français est la langue
officielle du québec et le nouveau
brunswick est la seule province
je paraphrase billen donc
vous avez des assurances sur vos
demandes mans est ce que ce n'est pas
suffisant ça quand je dis c'est que je
pense je pense que les organismes
signataires on était vraiment d'accord
avec probablement 95 % du niveau et
blanc effectivement comme je l'aï dit
tantôt la ministre julie hall intentions
puis en vouloir de reconnaître la
capacité du nouveau brunswick livre
blanc il ya la volonté politique vous
voulez dire c'est sur exactement miauton
veut juste s'assurer que nos demandes
soient encore entendus puisque c'est une
demande qu'on a eu depuis des messages
la donne à chose que j'aimerais c'est
qu'il ya un projet de loi qui est déposé
et que mal en contre malencontreusement
malheureusement ces spécificités là se
retrouvent pas dans le projet de loi
dont le jeu donné un avertissement puis
dont la toujours continuer les
discussions avec laminé jolie et c'est
pour ça que demain on a des grands
comptes avec amélie julie les 18 19
organismes
je reviens aux nouveaux produits à votre
province là où vous êtes à 7 dans cette
province
est-ce qu'on peut être servi en français
ça pose problème ça dépend des régions
qui malheureusement c'est l'exemple que
je donne toujours aux gens qui me pose
la question mais la pandémie a démontré
qu'il y avait encore un grand un grand
écart entre l'égalité réelle et vraiment
c'est l'égalité réelle seront en visio
nouveau brunswick en edu comme l'outil
linguistique qui se glisse pas sur le
terrain le meilleur exemple c'est
pendant la pandémie
chaque jour notre premier ministre qui
muni d'un grand dauphin de se présenter
de donner des conférences de presse en
anglais avec la traduction simultanée
écoute ça prend pas un baccalauréat en
traduction vous savoir que la traduction
sait jamais si jamais exact donc moi
j'ai eu beaucoup de membres qui se sont
tournés vers les conférences de presse à
monsieur legault pour recevoir
l'information de lakovic ça c'est grave
parce que c'est pas ton gouvernement
donc pas la même réalité celle de 10
heures exactement donc il ya beaucoup de
gens à l'andorre du nouveau brunswick
qui pensent qu'on est un paradis
linguistique l'appui que c'est ça va
très bien au niveau du bilinguisme et ça
c'est loin d'être la cause et même on ne
vous prend ce but que le gouvernement
s'apprête à réviser la loi sur les
langues officielles
ou est-ce qu'on en est je sais qu'il ya
eu récemment la nomination de
commissaire qui vont superviser cette
réforme
cette prévision est ce que vous êtes
optimiste mais écoute le processus est
très en temps lorsque la dent après il
ya eu la vision sont en 2013 puis ont eu
deux à faire des travaux et là
présentement ils sont néamoins lyon
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2021 a déposé un
premier projet de lourds donc les on y
est on est dans l'émoi présentement ils
ont un nom dans les années fait
effectivement tout de suite le processus
mais a juste de commencer et on est déjà
on est déjà entrée en vigueur puis en
plus de cela le gouvernement a voulu
mêler les questions d d'immersion
française là dedans donc là on l'est
toujours pâle que le processus soit un
prêt suspect elle belle ou ce qu'on
mélange plein de choses mais les comme
ça je pense que les curriculum des du
commissaire font en sorte que le
processus va être beaucoup plus on a
beaucoup plus confiance au processus
présentement qu'on l'était probablement
trop souvent passées avant la longue et
c'est ma dernière question est quelles
sont les principales demandes de la
société de l'acadie du nouveau brunswick
par rapport à cette réforme provincial
mais bien évidemment je pourrais élaboré
par blizzard et déjà parce que notre des
mois sur la question le programme fini
mon les rangers pour que soit 100 pages
écrit baisse et ce je pense que ça
démontre et si le premier ministre
allait devant le public dans les
conférences de presse à l'ehpad en
anglais puis à voir la traduction
simultanée mais d'autres on veut
vraiment mettre des dispositions pour
que si la personne peut pas parler
efficacement dans les deux langues
officielles
va doit se faire remplacer par quelqu'un
donc au moment où on parle au nom de
l'institution percevait devoir tester
son côté même si le premier ministre
doit déléguer les tâches à quelqu'un
d'autre qui peut parler efficacement
régulant il ya toujours la question
d'obligation de la capacité de parler et
de comprendre clairement les deux
langues officielles pour l'ensemble des
agents de l'assemblée législative
il ya toute la question des travailleurs
dans la fonction publique la langue de
travail pour les fonctionnaires
il ya eu vraiment désintégration du
français dans la fonction
public et nous une autre fonction
publique et beaucoup centralisés dans la
capitale qui plus est il est
malheureusement floride est beaucoup
plus quand on aimerait rajouter les
dispositions pour s'assurer que l'écran
les fonctionnaires acadiens et
francophones puissent parler dans leur
langue ils travaillent dans leur langue
de leur choix
écoutez j'espère qu'on aura d'autres
occasions de parler de la réforme
provincial et dans la région fédérale je
vous remercie beaucoup monsieur
alexandre cédric douce et je rappelle
que vous êtes président de la société de
l'acadie du nouveau-brunswick merci
beaucoup